the face of historic achievement in
Canadian politics the first non-white
federal political party leader jug meat
sing of the leftist NDP the New
Democrats a Canadian whose parents came
from India he's a Sikh who wears his
uncut hair bound up in a turban because
of his faith nearly half a million six
live in Canada and they've long been
politically active Chuck meet Singh is a
role model for a new generation he was
one of the people that inspired me to
get into politics he's always been a
community organizer you know when I was
20 and I was looking for somewhere to be
he taught me the importance of politics
in this Toronto suburb nearly every
candidate is a Sikh Justin Trudeau's
liberals won all five seats in the 2015
election now with opinion polls showing
him less popular than four years ago
there's a chance for another party to
make gains old fashioned retailed
politics
putting in lawn signs and knocking on
doors that's what it takes to get
attention in a constituency like this
one very diverse and where the voters
need to see and hear from their
candidates Sikh temples known as Gord
Juarez prepare meals for all who come no
matter their religion it's an article of
faith this is the largest Gurdwara in
North America with tens of thousands of
worshippers these days most second and
third generation Canadians all political
opinions can be found I think sometimes
a mistake is made that the Sikh
community somehow homogenous or thinks
alike or you know always walks lockstep
with one another know there's diversity
within the diversity right there's those
folks that have a lot of different
opinions during a trip to India last
year Justin Trudeau faced intense
criticism for putting Sikh community
interests ahead of Canada's with one of
its most important trading partners
supporters of the prime minister denied
wrongdoing and said he or any other
Canadian leader has to listen to voters
you want every vote doesn't matter what
the background is of the voter
and so you reach out with respect to the
trip to India that did not improve
Trudeau's image she came across as the
Bollywood figure and he was sort of
Lampoon not just in the country but I
think internationally and I think he was
very poorly served by that foreign
policy aside elections are won here and
across the country on the basic
bread-and-butter issues improving the
economy creating jobs and keeping the
country safe and prosperous Daniel aquel
Jazeera Brampton Ontario